you're saying that in 2007 there was a  moment where you were almost trading for  kobe yeah i thought it was done please  tell me that story i was in dancing with  the stars i was going back and forth  with dr bus i think he called me  actually and said look we think we might  be partying ways with kobe i remember it  vividly because there was a pa named  elvis who was working as it was just  lakers lakers lakers lakers lakers i  used to give him a hard time he'd give  me a hard time and we had just gone to  the finals the year before so it started  to happen i started telling him about it  the minute i told elvis it all fell  apart i guess mitch cupchak taught kobe  into staying dirk was like i would have  traded me for kobe and i'm like no i'm  not going to trade you jerk that's the  whole point right wow yeah we would have  been something else